Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie Guardians of the Galaxy 3 is out
everywhere now this will be my post credit scene
video because there is a lot going on with the
future of all the characters and how it connects
with everything that's coming up like Avengers 5
King Dynasty and Secret Wars so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos we're also in
the middle of a couple really big giveaways so
I'll name a few winners later in this video but
the giveaways will continue for a while careful
for spoilers for the movie if you have not seen
it yet because we have to talk about the end
but at the end of the movie probably one of the
biggest surprises even though a lot of things
that we all predicted happened a couple of the
biggest surprises were that none of the main team
members ended up dying really thought they were
going to wind up killing off drags but most of
them do leave the team like a lot of them were
talking about this being their last Guardians of
the Galaxy movie Last Marvel movie Drax ends up
caring for all the high evolutionaries reject
experiments and kids that they rescued from
his base at the end of the film completing his
Arc from the first movie with him becoming a
father again originally he'd sworn to kill Thanos
because he he was responsible for the death of his
wife and child after they got rid of ronin and
killed Thanos during Avengers endgame he'd been
spinning his wheels just unsure of what direction
his life should take like what his purpose should
be in living now his purpose is in being a father
to all these new kids that they rescued nebula
finally comes to terms with herself she finally
understands who she is who she wants to be in the
universe feels good about herself after all
the years of torture from Thanos telling her
she wasn't good enough replacing all of her body
parts to make her stronger her story in that way
is meant to be similar to Rocket's origin story
the way the high evolutionary modified him to
make him better so to speak she leaves the team to
become the new administrator of nowhere the giant
head of the celestial which I've talked about
in previous videos which they actually showed
us during the eternals movie like the full
version of the Eternal they do wind up using
nowhere as a really cool weapon against the high
evolutionary during the movie too the Guardians of
the Galaxy had actually purchased nowhere from The
Collector after Avengers endgame proving that he's
also still alive we thought that he died during
Avengers Infinity War but he's still alive out
there but during the events of the holiday special
they had already owned nowhere they owned the
entire head and even though the original Guardians
team went their separate ways collectively they
all still own it it doesn't solely belong to
nebula Now by herself but she's permanently
taking care of it the younger version of Gamora
goes back to continue leading the ravagers which
she was doing at the beginning of the movie She
and Star-Lord don't end the movie together because
she's fundamentally a different person than Peter
Quill's version of Gamora and a lot of the movie
is him coming to terms with that mantis leaves to
travel the universe by herself just learning about
things because she'd been trapped cooped up for
so long by her and Peter Quill's father ego The
Living Planet the only members from the original
Guardians roster who stay on the team are Rocket
and Groot I don't consider crackling to be part
of the original roster because he only joined the
team after the second movie in Cosmo the space
dog only joined the team after Avengers end game
but the new guardian's roster is rocket leading
the team Groot who's evolved again into like the
gigachad version of himself he looks more like
King Groot from the comics in the games with a
big crown on his head in the way he's bigger
than the original Groot was he's meant to be
the original groot's son or the closest thing to
his offspring he's not the same group just regrown
again like the comics he's a totally new person
craglin who's finally gotten good at using yandu's
Fin and his Arrow weapon he's been wearing it full
time since Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
and he's had it since the end of Guardians 2.
then Cosmo the space dog who we saw working with
the team in the holiday special in the totally new
members replacing the ones who also left are Adam
Warlock who he predicted was going to join the
team eventually anyway in the comics we became
a member of the Guardians of the Galaxy during
Annihilation and then later in the comics he's
continuing his quest to understand reality people
morality just in general kind of like Vision did
after Avengers Age of Ultron they're very similar
characters in that way Ultra powerful beings who
were effectively born yesterday so during the
movie he's gone up like this God tier powerful
person with the mind the emotional capacity of a
child but that's basically the way Adam Warlock
story in the comics played out he's created he
rebels against his creators and then leaves to
travel the universe to just learn about everything
on his own the next new member is phyla-vell who's
kind of like the new version of Quasar from the
comics or will become Quasar in the future she's
meant to be one of the more powerful beings that
the high evolutionary was experimenting on kind
of like he was doing with Adam Warlock because
it's revealed the high evolutionary created The
Sovereign so effectively he created Adam Warlock I
did a whole other video for the phyla-vell origin
story for Quasar she's basically meant to be an
artificially created copy of genus fell the son
of the original Captain Marvel in the comics and
their mother was an eternal from the Planet Titan
like Thanos like the same kind of Eternal so both
their mothers and fathers were meant to be these
Ultra powerful beings which is why phyla-vell
is so powerful as far as I can tell she doesn't
have the quantum bands yet so I think that'll be
like some future story that they can tell in other
Marvel movies but James Gunn said that he's going
to DC so it won't be James Gunn telling that story
The Last new member of the new guard guardian's
roster is blurp who's another one of the high
evolutionary Creations they rescue there's been
a bunch of jokes about him and all the trailers
too and during the post-credits scene the new
Guardians team is on a planet getting ready to
protect a group of townspeople from an invading
Army of animals but they're sitting around
casually just joking with each other about who
their favorite music bands are phylavel says her
favorites are Britney Spears and corn which are
like two diametrically opposite tones of bands
like completely different I think the Easter
egg there is just for her personality like she
is a little girl technically so she likes Britney
Spears like cute little girl stuff that you would
expect but because she has this super dark origin
story she's this Ultra powerful being sometimes
her personality swings super dark and she's super
hardcore and terrifying craglin says his favorite
music is the man Garth Brooks the country singer
he really likes the classics and because Cosmo's
accent is so thick I actually couldn't make out
who her favorite band was if you think you heard
in the theater correctly write it below in the
comments I've still got to see the movie movie
A couple more times for my full breakdown in
Easter eggs video just because there's so much
stuff that happened but Adam warlock's favorite
music band is Adrian Belew who was a guitarist
who ended up working with King Crimson who go back
to the 60s they're like a Prague rock group and
I think the Easter egg there is that he likes
bands from around the time that he debuted in
the comics because it's around the time that he
was created in Marvel Comics in Rocket says his
favorite song is actually huge Easter egg from
the original come and get your love Redbone song
at the very beginning of the first Guardians of
the Galaxy movie that was the song that Star-Lord
was listening to on the original mixtape on Morag
when he was kicking around water looking for the
Power Stone he says this one's kind of special
then cues up the song to play on star-lord's Zune
which he gave to Rocket when he left the team to
go back to Earth so rocket has all Peter Quill's
original mixtape music on azun and it's meant to
be a teaser that when they show up in the future
movies like this new Guardians roster they'll
still be listening to the same type of 70s music
because they still have the Zune they're also
still wearing all those brand new suits from the
annihilation comic book run I'm sure they'll show
up in future movies with different costume changes
just because everybody gets costume changes in
new movies they joke about who's going to be the
one to defeat the invading Army for the town like
oh no I'll do it I'll do it like it's no big deal
kraglan says he'll do it by himself just because
they treat it like it's not a big deal Rocket says
they should all do it together just so that it
goes faster and then he bumps Groot who's been
lying down taking a nap he rolls over and is super
huge like I said the gigachad version of Groot now
and as they start running towards the army of
animals the music swells up come and get your
love and it slams to credits with the song playing
really nice callback to the beginning of the first
movie The Arc of the team is now complete even
though this team will continue in future Marvel
movies probably not coming back till Avengers 5
King Dynasty or Avengers 6 Secret Wars after that
they probably won't do Guardians of the Galaxy 4
as the movie because Disney said they're not doing
fourth sequels anymore for any of these movies
but the team will just keep crossing over with
other space-based movies the second post credit
scene is a funny scene of Star-Lord who's gone
back to Earth now to live with his grandfather
who he saw in the first movie and the idea is
that he's finally made peace with his past the
death of his mother so he's finally cool to come
back and actually live on planet Earth again the
whole idea with his character before this is that
he hated Earth just because it reminded him of his
mother so much so he tried as much as he could to
stay away from Earth even during Avengers end game
when he actually had to come back to fight Thanos
he left as fast as possible after they killed him
and in the actual scene he's just jokingly talking
to his grandfather about Kevin Bacon being super
weird and Casual everyday problems like mowing the
lawn very mundane regular human problems and it's
meant to be a sign that he's finally found some
peace and doesn't have any Universe ending threats
that he's worried about at the current moment it
is also a joke about the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special when Peter Quill actually met
the real Kevin Bacon and they celebrated Christmas
together like the actor Kevin Bacon is now Candace
of the Marvel Universe and they're saying he is
super weird then at the very end of the credits
a special message says the legendary Star-Lord
will return into special Guardians of the Galaxy
style font and it's meant to be both a joke about
the original Guardians of the Galaxy movie where
nobody knew who Peter Quill was because he called
himself the legendary star like he was the only
person who actually referred to himself as
legendary another name you might know me by
Star-Lord who Star-Lord man legendary outlaw
guys and it's a reference to Star-Lord coming back
in Avengers 5 and Avengers six because Chris Pratt
has said in real life that he's definitely coming
back for more Marvel movies even though James Gunn
is leaving to lead DC movies and some of the other
actors have said this is their very last Marvel
movie he's like no no I'm definitely coming back
publicly the only actors who have said they're
definitely done and aren't doing any more Marvel
movies are Zoe Saldana and Dave Batista like even
though nebula left the team Karen Gillen has
said that she's open to coming back in more
Marvel movies if you spotted any other Easter eggs
in the actual post-credits scenes that I didn't
talk about in the video just write them Below
in the comments my full breakdown Easter eggs
with the entire movie will post Friday it'll be a
giant video there's so much that happens be sure
to go see the movie as soon as possible if you
haven't yet there's so much stuff we have to talk
about GearRob and Codyimel2997 congratulations
you're the giveaway winners from my last couple
of Guardians of the Galaxy videos please contact
me on my about page of my channel so I can get
your contact details now the giveaways are still
open there's still a bunch of the free stuff that
I have to give away so those will continue for a
while I'll name the next giveaway winners in my
full breakdown Easter eggs video tomorrow everyone
click here for that I'll update the link as soon
as I post it and click here for my brand new
secret Invasion trailer video and Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!